while countries across the globe
continue to seal borders and lock down
citizens the country that saw kovat 19's
primary infection for the first time
reported no new local cases in China the
only new coronavirus patients were
imported from abroad as construction and
manufacturing resumes after months of
shutdown the epicenter for the virus
Wuhan City and the surrounding Hubei
Province reported no new cases also for
the first time we are delighted to see
this double zero increase this means
today we have seen the dawn after so
many days of hard effort there's been an
uptick of infections in South Korea this
after a small cluster was discovered at
a nursing home to help offset the
economic impact of the corona virus the
government announced a support package
to help small businesses with two
previous packages the total financial
aid now tops 39 billion dollars for
tonight we should think about ways to
support those who have suffered from
income loss or lost their jobs due to
the coroner virus the asian stock
markets continue to struggle as concerns
over economic disruption from the virus
continues South Korea's kospi led most
of the region's major markets in losses
Thailand announced its biggest
single-day jump in coronavirus cases at
least 60 some of them were people
returning from a mass gathering of
Muslim missionaries in neighboring
Malaysia Thailand has closed some of its
border crossings with its southern
neighbor one of japan's biggest tourist
draws is cherry blossom season now in
full swing but because of fear over
spreading the virus viewing parties and
picnics are discouraged and events have
been canceled
the Japanese government just announced
the tourist numbers for last month were
down over 58 percent that's the biggest
drop in nine years since the tsunami and
earthquake in 2011 that triggered the
Fukushima nuclear disaster
Scott Heidler al-jazeera